قبل اعوام كان من المستبعد ربما التفكير
في ان يكون الهداف التاريخي لفريق ليفربول
الانجليزي من جنسيه عربيه لكن محمد صلاح
استطاع كسر المالوف ونجح في ان يحقق ذلك
وبعيدا عن صلاح اللاعب فان حياه النجم
المصريه الخاصه تبدو بسيطه للغايه بالنسبه
لغذاء محمد صلاح فانه لا يؤمن بفكره
الحميه والرجيم للحفاظ على لياقته وبدلا
من ذلك فانه يعتمد على نظام غذائي متوازن
بعيدا عن السكر بشكل شبه كامل على عكس
الكثير من لاعبي الفرق الذين يفضلون ان
يعيشوا قريبا من ناديها فضل صلاح العيش في
مدينه مانشستر يونايتد على بعد نحو ساعه
من ناديه ليفربول مع عائلته المكونه من
زوجه وطفلتين وبعيدا عن كره القدم يحب
صلاح العديد من الرياضات منها تجديف الصيد
وتنس كذلك الجري وركوب دراجات حيث شوهد
خلال اجازاته الصيفيه وهو يمارس هذه
الالعاب بحسب صحيفه تايمز فان صلاح يمتلك
شركه الاستثمارات العقاريه ام او اس ويل
ستيت وشركه اخرى للاجارات العقاريه وهي
بيزنس 22 فضلا عن مصنع للاسمنت وتقدر ثروه
محمد صلاح بحسب فورد باكثر من 90 مليون
دولار امريكي
[موسيقى]